good morning Hank it's Friday anchor
Salman Wednesday was brilliant the best
song ever written about particle physics
frankly Hank it was almost intimidating
ly good like it made me sad I'm not more
talented I mean I realized I write books
and to some people that qualifies as a
talent but let me remind you Hank
Lauren Conrad writes books but anyway
Hank there's something I've been wanting
to ask you I've always had this dream
that just like we have a collaborative
video channel some day you know this is
awkward but maybe someday we could be on
stage playing music together and I know
that I can't sing and that you played
the guitar that I don't have any rhythm
so I couldn't do bass or drums but Hank
for the last several months I've been
learning a musical instrument in the
hopes that you know like maybe I could
be in your band come on green you can do
it
that's right Hank I want to be your sing
of a jig player I mean I've been
thinking about it Hank what is keeping
you from being the next Justin Bieber
you've got the lyrics you can play the
guitar you've got a great look it's a
little nerdy but it works and your pork
song on Wednesday was a great example of
how you always write about subjects that
matter or at least the subject of matter
Hank what's standing between you and the
next level in your career to paraphrase
the great Christopher Walken you need
more sing of a jig now Hank I know what
you're wondering why should you hire me
to be your singing magic player I mean
anyone with two hands can make cinema
jigs harmonize and that's true Hank
anyone with two hands can make two
singer magics harmonize but can they
make
ah for singham a jigs Harmonized no they
can't because they have not been
practicing the instrument of the cinema
jig non-stop for months like I have and
it's not just harmony Hank I can make
melodies mmm by the way I gotta know
what you knew about these things before
today because you don't have a child for
our friend marina bought them for Henry
and after about 45 seconds of playing
with one he looked up at me and his eyes
I said hey Dad quick favor I'm gonna
need you to go to the store and buy me
five hundred thousand cinema jigs and
Henry just woke up from his nap so I
have to go but that's all I wanted to
say I just wanted to throw my hat into
the ring as a potential sing my jig
player if you know you ever find
yourself in need of one nerdfighters
there's only one week left to pre-order
Hank's t-shirt tastic ode to giraffes
who love giraffes link in the doobly-doo
and Hank I'll see you on Monday